this took me like 30 years to figure out
if you ask a disagreeable person what
what he wants say or she wants they'll
tell you right away they know it's like
this is what I want and this is how I'm
going to get it but agreeable people
especially if they're really agreeable
are so agreeable that they often don't
even know what they want because they're
so accustomed to living for other people
and to finding out what other people
want and to trying to make them
comfortable and so forth that it's
harder for them to find a sense of their
own desires as they move through life
say what you think tell the truth about
what you think there's going to be
things you think that you think are
nasty and harsh and they probably are
nasty and harsh but they're also
probably true and you need to bring
those up to the Forefront and deliver
the message and it's not straightforward
at all because agreeable people do not
like conflict not at all they smooth the
water where conflict emerges the problem
with that is it's not a very good medium
to long-term strategy as lots lots of
times there are things you have to talk
about because they're not going to go
away
if you're harmless you're not virtuous
you're just harmless you're like a
rabbit rabbit isn't virtuous it's just
can't do anything except get eaten it's
not virtuous if you're a monster and you
don't act monstrously then you're
virtuous but you also have to be a
monster you're going to negotiate for a
raise or a or a status shift you better
have your resume at hand all polished up
and nowhere else you're going to look
for a job and you better be able to get
one because otherwise you're just you're
weak and you will not win the
negotiation and if you're too agreeable
so your conflict avoidant
you will make less money across time
that's already been well established and
that's because you don't have teeth not
enough and so in the little micro
contest that you're going to have every
day you're going to incrementally lose
to people who are more aggressive who
have bigger teeth and that's what
happens so don't let that happen one of
the things you have to be careful of if
you're agreeable is not to be exploited
because you'll line up to be exploited
if you are not capable of Cruelty you
are absolutely a victim to anyone who is
and so part of the reason that people go
watch anti-heroes and villains is
because there's a part of them crying
out for the incorporation of the monster
within them which is what gives them
strength of character and self-respect
because it's impossible to respect
yourself until you grow teeth and if you
grow teeth then you realize that you're
somewhat dangerous and or maybe somewhat
seriously dangerous and then you might
be more willing to demand that you treat
yourself with respect and other people
do the same thing and so that doesn't
mean that being cruel is better than not
being cruel what it means is that being
able to be cruel and then not being
cruel is better than not being able to
be cruel if you're competent at fighting
that actually decreases the probability
that you're going to have to fight
because when someone pushes you you'll
be able to respond with confidence which
is very much equivalent to a show of
dominance is going to be enough to make
the bully back off
and so the strength that you develop in
your monstrousness is actually the best
guarantee of Peace your being is limited
and and flawed and fragile
um you're like the genie which is genius
in the little tiny uh lamp you know this
immense potential but constrained in
this tiny little living space but the
fact that you have limitations
means that the plot of your life is the
overcoming of those limitations and that
if you didn't have limitations well
there wouldn't be a plot and maybe there
would be no life and so that's part of
the reason why perhaps you have to
accept the fact that you're flawed and
insufficient and and live with it and
consider it a precondition for being
it's a reasonable idea but if you only
know how to behave you're just a
domesticated house cat or or a lap dog
you have to push beyond the Persona and
that's what the integration of the
Shadow does from the union perspective
it's like to pull that
monster that's being edited out of you
pull that back in and to allow that to
reveal itself within your increasingly
sophisticated way of being
and then you're not just a Persona and
one of the things I tell agreeable
people especially if they're
conscientious is say what you think tell
the truth about what you think there's
going to be things you think that you
think are nasty and harsh and they
probably are nasty and harsh but they're
also probably true and you need to bring
those up to the Forefront and deliver
the message and it's not straightforward
at all because agreeable people do not
like conflict not at all they smooth the
water the problem with that is it's not
a very good medium to long-term strategy
right because lots lots of times there
are things you have to talk about
because they're not going to go away and
the advantage to having a
well-socialized disagreeable person is
that they really don't let much get in
their way it's really useful to
investigate the viewpoints of people who
have opposing views to yours because
they'll tell you things not only will
they tell you things you don't know
they'll also tell you how to see the
world in ways that you don't see it
and they'll also have skills that you
don't have that you could develop so for
example if you're an introverted person
it's very useful to watch an extroverted
person because the extroverted person
has ways of being in the social world
that aren't natural to you that you can
use this to improve your toolkit and if
you're disagreeable one of the best
things to do with disagreeable people
especially if that's alienating them
from other people for example because it
can get the person to do something for
someone else once a day just as a
practice and learn how to do it maybe
you can wake the circuit up you know if
you think that it's lying dormant in you
which is probably right you know I think
we have a very wide range of
propensities within us some are switched
on but I think that if you put yourself
in the right situation or walk yourself
through the right exercises you can
switch some of these other things on as
well but it takes work and and
dedication and discipline you know so if
you're hyper extroverted you should
probably learn to shut up at parties now
and then and listen just to see what's
going on to see if you can manage it and
if you're introverted well then you
should learn how to speak in public and
to and to learn how to go to parties
without hiding in the corner and saying
nothing to anyone knowing if you're
agreeable then you need to learn how to
be disagreeable so people can't push you
around and if you're disagreeable you
learn you need to learn how to be
agreeable so and the same thing applies
even in the conscientious domain it's
like if you're too conscientious you
need to learn to relax and let go a
little bit but as a as a basis for
negotiation between adults it's like
sorry it's it's insufficient you have to
you have to be a bit of a monster so
that you can say no and so a lot of what
you do in in psychotherapy is treat
people's anxiety and depression that's a
huge chunk of it help them straighten
out the way they think that's a huge
chunk of it but another chunk of it is
well let's toughen you up you know let's
put you in a position where you can
bargain let's teach you how to assert
yourself and stand up for yourself and
that's assertiveness training and it's a
huge chunk of psychotherapy and you need
to you need to learn it it's like
because part of how you regulate your
interactions with other people is to
negotiate
and you cannot negotiate unless you can
say no you can't do it and it causes
conflict to say no and if you don't like
conflict which is basically the
definition of being agreeable then you
can't tolerate the conflict and so then
you can't negotiate on your own behalf
and so then you keep losing and you're
bullied and you know it's it's not good
then you get resentful and and it's
really not good so you have to
develop your inner monster a little bit
you don't make men safe by making them
weak
in fact they're much more dangerous when
they're weak because they'll stab you in
the back when they get the chance
or take advantage of you when you when
they get the chance you make men safe
let's say by making them strong and then
by making sure that they're disciplined